but first tonight the endless hate rage
hysteria misinformation
from joe biden the media mob democrats
big tech
the woke corporate cowards it's now
hitting if you can believe it
new levels of derangement and psychosis
because the outright lies that are being
spewed about georgia's new voting law
and proposals in texas it exposes
just how corrupt just how bitterly
partisan
our major institutions are and how they
become
they're like well pravda pure state-run
propaganda outlets and they are less
interested
in truth than ever before so here on
this program we're going to do the job
the mob and the media will never do
and we will separate back from fiction
for you and lay out what the law
is and what it is not and we will expose
how abusively biased the media
is the double standards are the
misinformation campaign
being waged against election integrity
oh yeah
and delaware's voting laws far more
restrictive than the new georgia law
we begin where joe biden began his lies
this bill does not
end voting hours early joe if you're
awake i doubt it
in fact it creates more early voting
more days to vote more flexibility to
vote
it adds another saturday to vote and
even keeps the
precious ballot drop boxes that
democrats love
here's south carolina senator tim scott
pushing back against
all of the left's election lies take a
look
how can you have a legitimate
conversation
about something so sacred as voting
how can you distort the facts so
terribly
that you're willing you're willing to to
bring to bring back the concept of a
poll tax
or the concept of jim crow
you only do that when you have nothing
to stand on
don't weaponize
race be powerful and destructive way
when so many people fought and died so
that
i could be your senator so i can stand
here and have a conversation with you
and furthermore instead of having two
standards two
tiered signature system the bill in
georgia actually
strengthens the absentee ballot process
so we have the same standard for every
ballot in the state of georgia
in-person voting absentee voting and yes
you're allowed to bring food and water
when you vote
and yes election workers can hand it out
also
just not partisan organizations within
150 feet from the voting booth
the new law also requires a voter id
or any state issued id or social
security number
to even get an absentee ballot which is
simple common sense
should of course be a requirement for
the preservation of the sanctity of the
ballot
and to ensure that georgians and
americans
have faith in their election process and
that they in the end will have
confidence in its results
and you know what else you know think
about what you need to show an id for
let's say you want to go visit joe at
the white house
want to go to visit go to the white
house you need a picture id you want to
go to the u.s capitol visit the people's
house
meet your congressman or congresswoman
yeah you need a picture id
go to the democratic national convention
get on an airplane
buy a house apply for a mortgage buy
alcohol buy
cigarettes even by my famous jewel pods
like here
or if you want to apply for food stamps
apply for a job apply for welfare
programs
if you want to apply for medicare
medicaid apply for unemployment if you
want to drive
buy or rent a car purchase a gun adopt a
pet
rent a hotel room pick up a prescription
at your
drug store donate blood purchase some
cold and allergy medicines like
all allegra d and on and on and on and
furthermore voter id is
overwhelmingly popular look at this poll
from the ap it found a whopping 72
percent of you the american
people you approve requiring photo ids
to vote
but joe biden the democrats they don't
want you to know these facts sadly
he got caught once again playing the
race card
dividing this country is fueling nothing
but vicious
divisive racial rhetoric about jim crow
and voter suppression with zero evidence
and no facts behind it and biden's lies
are so bad that even the washington post
is calling him out for his lives he got
four pinocchios
for his claims about voter suppression
now this is the same biden you know the
one that said we're going to put you all
back in chains and
you can't go to a 7-11 or dunkin donuts
unless you have a slight indian accent
or what he said about uh president obama
for the first time
you got an african-american that's clean
articulate and bright
man that's storybook and earlier today
our own peter ducey pressed circle back
jenn saki on the issue let's take a look
he said the law would end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting up
and he said it would end voting hours
early so working people can't cast
their vote after their shift is over but
the washington post
gave that claim four pinocchios because
that part of the law gives counties the
option to
extend voting hours and so i'm just
curious
if the president is going to change the
way that he's talking well
fundamentally the president doesn't
believe it should be made harder to vote
he believes it should be easier but the
thing he said
has been determined by election law
experts to be not true
so i'm just curious if he's going to
stop saying well again
i think we can the fact checkers will
also
tell you that this bill does not make it
easier for people across
the state of georgia to vote and that's
where he has concerns
circle back propaganda saki he got
caught red-handed joe got caught
red-handed they're
lying and get this the irony george's
voting law
is far far far less restrictive
than joe's beloved home state of
delaware for example
delaware has no in-person early voting
georgia has
17 days of in-person early voting
delaware requires
specific excuses if you want to vote
absentee in georgia anyone can vote
absentee
in delaware there are no ballot drop
boxes and georgia drop boxes are still
available
under the new law and one box per county
is required by the new law
and by the way it's the same joe biden
remember he's the guy
lying about jim crow 2.0 that's the same
joe
biden who was worried about our schools
if they became
integrated becoming quote racial jungles
that's when he partnered with the former
klansmen to stop that from happening
joe biden the same person that worked
with robert kkk byrd
preventing the integration of schools
and calling out black youth as predators
on our streets
and said if you don't vote for him you
ain't black
now where was the outrage from all these
pathetic woke corporations
like major league baseball delta
airlines american airlines coca-cola
on all of this now 200 apparently
corporations
you want to get involved in this game
get ready because it'll happen
why the hell did any of these companies
get involved in the first place with no
knowledge
but give joe biden a total pass in terms
of
his history and why do they want to
amplify
lies about what this law is and is not
and use it as another excuse to lie
smear and besmirch
conservatives did any of these companies
actually read the law i doubt it
and by the way do they have any idea
what it actually does i doubt that too
did they just surrender
to the mob of the woke extremists and
cancel culture because
they are a bunch of corporate cowards
who would rather demonize you we
the american people and spew lies and
get yelled at by loud liberals on
twitter and i have a specific message
for the commissioner rob manfred of the
mlb
well why are you going to bat against
what is better voter integrity in
georgia
than delaware joe state or new york
schumer's state
why are you taking the all-star game out
of atlanta
which is going to cost georgia and
specifically fulton county
cobb county democrats yeah a hundred
million dollars in revenue
are you really that spineless are you
really that stupid
because the league apparently has no
problem well mlb
they do business in china and we're
learning tonight that mlb
is bolstering its ties with one of
china's largest tech companies
which is backed by yep ccp and actually
cracked down
on an nba executive back in 2019 who
supported
the pro-democracy movement in hong kong
and by the way can you pick
pick up will call tickets for a baseball
game sporting event concert
if you don't have a picture id no you
cannot
senator marco rubio had this strong
message for the commissioner
saying in a statement quote i am under
no illusion that major league baseball
will sacrifice business revenue on
behalf of its
alleged corporate values similarly i'm
under no illusion
that you intend to resign as a member
from augusta national golf club
to do so would require a personal
sacrifice
as opposed to the woke corporate virtue
signaling
of moving the all-star game from atlanta
and why is joe biden not being held
accountable for his role
in starting and fueling the entire fire
peter ducey asked circle back jenn
soccer to explain that
take a look i know that you
made the point that he did not dictate
the league
move the all-star game out of georgia
but he likes to say
the words of a president matter he said
he would strongly support
if players in the league wanted to do
that and they did it
so does he think that the pga should
move the masters tournament that begins
this week out of georgia
i'm not here to call for anyone on
behalf of the president or the vice
president or anyone
to take steps in reaction to the law in
georgia
the president was asked a direct
question and the context of the question
was also
around the league meeting to discuss
this exact issue
and he answered the question joe in
favor of boycotting the 2022 winter
olympics
in beijing let's be clear there's
nothing controversial about the georgia
law there's nothing controversial
about wanting free and fair elections
there's definitely nothing controversial
about showing an id
to vote unless of course you want to
cheat
so why have major corporations chosen to
sell out
and surrender to the democrats lies a
misinformation campaign
are these companies now will they be as
principled and outspoken
against those 22 22 winter olympics in
beijing
are they going to be sponsoring those
olympics in china and will joe ask the
olympics
to be moved to another country it's bad
business it's pathetic virtue signaling
it's a massive hypocrisy and double
standard and we will continue to expose
it